jaime tamaris productor y director
guayaquileño ha trabajado en obras
exitosas como el amante la gata sobre el
tejado caliente el grinch scrooge el
mago de öz entre otras en 2014 emprende
el proyecto de microteatro una
iniciativa que surge de la necesidad de
crear un circuito de salas alternativas
en guayaquil el cual se ha mantenido
hasta la actualidad con sede en
samborondón y miraflores
[Aplausos]
y voy a hablar un poco sobre espacios
escénicos espacios y sin ecos
independientes alternativos para eso me
gustaría comenzar hablando sobre qué es
un espacio escénico cuando hablamos de
un espacio escénico normalmente
imaginamos un escenario más o menos como
este una tarima de madera poco más
elevada un público sentado en un sitio
donde asistimos vemos un evento y luego
nos vamos pero realmente un espacio
escénico nueces
me gustaría compartir algo que aprendí
durante mis años estudios
cuando estudiaba teatro en la escuela
cristina rota
entendí que el espacio escénico es algo
que se crea es algo que hacemos en
conjunto ya decía meyerhold es una
convención es un acuerdo que se consigue
entre el expositor o los artistas y el
público como sucede esto
cuando dos artistas salen un escenario y
se empiezan a hablar de verdad y
escucharse verdad y están verdaderamente
presentes se genera una especie de
dimensión entre ellos algo pasa algo
sucede y eso que sucede es algo a lo que
nosotros podemos conectarnos como
audiencia como público
esa conexión que surge crea una
dimensión donde se genera un espacio y
un tiempo ese espacio y ese tiempo es un
escenario eso es un espacio escénico es
algo que hacemos construimos en conjunto
entonces partiendo de este principio
ustedes se habrán notado que en los
últimos años en nuestra ciudad han
empezado a surgir muchos espacios
alternativos no solamente el micro
teatro microteatro comenzó sí hace dos
años pero desde hace diez años ya
empiezan a ver espacios salas
alternativas en guayaquil en los últimos
dos años es verdad que han surgido más y
eso es una una pregunta interesante
porque de dónde sale empezaron aparejado
surgir estos espacios y porque además
yo creo que lo interesante es justamente
la necesidad de generar esos encuentros
de los que hablaba anteriormente estos
puntos
donde tenemos la oportunidad de vernos
de hablar de compartir hoy mismo este
espacio donde estamos todos compartiendo
estamos hablando y dando ideas y
escuchando y devolviendo es una forma de
encuentro un intercambio que está
sucediendo y nosotros estamos generando
este espacio entonces
durante esos años que walking empezado a
aparecer estos espacios tienen surgen de
la necesidad de una ciudad que empieza a
demandar ya formas alternativas de
expresión de consumo cultural los
espacios convencionales los teatros
grandes están muy bien son los
tradicionales los que la mayoría
conocemos ya pero estos espacios nuevos
que se abren en la ciudad son espacios
para experimentación funcionan como
laboratorios y son muy necesarios en una
ciudad porque de alguna forma generan
y experiencias distintas
y nosotros cuando empezamos a producir
en guayaquil ya hace 8 años que tenemos
nuestra productora como mencionaba la
introducción hemos producido algunas
obras que han tenido mucho éxito sobre
todo en salas grandes con grandes
audiencias una gran producción muchos
actores pero esos trabajan todo mucho
tiempo mucho dinero más producirlas y
teníamos que esperar un año entero para
poder levantar otra producción y crear
lo que queremos los artistas es tener
función cada noche o sea lo puedes
levantarte decir esta noche tengo
función entonces no podríamos tener
función todas las noches y fue desde ahí
desde esa necesidad desde esa necesidad
de encontrarnos con el público de
generar estos encuentros que decidimos
generar los espacios buscar los espacios
y ya hemos tenido algunos años no
solamente en micro teatro desde antes
empezamos a añadir espacios no
tradicionales casas abandonadas centros
comerciales que tenían locales cerrados
nosotros nos metíamos y hacíamos obras
de teatro
hicimos una adaptación de reservoir dogs
en the cost tarantino bueno cualquier
esquina que hubiéramos disponible que
estaba abierta a convertirse en un
escenario nosotros lo convertimos
tratamos de convertir a su mercenario
para que el público pudiera asistir y
nosotros poder mostrar nuestro trabajo
esto funcionó como un estímulo muy bueno
porque a partir de eso la gente empezó a
cambiar el 'chip' empezó a darse cuenta
de que ir al teatro no necesariamente es
ir a un edificio que se llama teatro ir
al teatro es ir a encontrarme con
alguien con un artista como el público
con el que va a compartir y creo que eso
no maravilloso del escenario que el
escenario es un espacio para compartir
para dialogar para vernos porque somos
como somos porque hacemos las cosas que
hacemos el escenario es el momento en el
cual todos entramos a acuerdo de que
esto que está pasando aquí es importante
y que va voy a tomar algo de él que me
van a entregar algo y voy a escuchar y
recibir
yo estoy muy sorprendido porque voy a
ser sincero cuando empezamos a hacer el
microteatro dijimos bueno donde lo
hacemos entonces el primer espacio que
tenemos a la mano era el mismo espacio
dónde estábamos trabajando tenemos estas
productoras esta productora queda en una
casa muy pequeñita en miraflores algunos
la conocen algunos por allí
tenemos cuatro habitaciones y un patio
interior y al final si no bueno
hagámoslo aquí y empezamos a trabajar a
buscarnos una obra para cada espacio y
al final no les no les cuento más al día
de hoy hemos tenido y hemos 22 mil 800
entradas han pasado más de 80 compañías
hemos tenido alrededor de 150 artistas
que han pasado casi todos los artes de
la ciudad han pasado por ahí y se ha
generado en un punto de cuento en un
dínamo que ha permitido a la escena web
quiera tener una constancia de la
producción y eso creo que ha sido el
mayor aporte microteatro el poder
tiene un punto donde la diversidad y la
constancia en el trabajo permite
enriquecer la producción de los artistas
locales eso fue realmente el resultado
que superó nuestras expectativas porque
al principio nosotros decimos bueno
seguramente vendrán nuestros amigos
nuestra familia estaremos como un mes
tratan de soportarlo pero fue
sorprendente la reacción del público
todo el mundo empezó a venir a preguntar
a de qué se trataba este micro teatro
cómo funciona
y creo que de alguna manera todos
salimos sorprendidos todos salimos
sorprendido yo soy el primero porque la
verdad como les digo yo pensé que iba a
venir nada con mi familia pero al final
vine al público
es lo más cautivante para un artista ver
que hay un público realmente en la
ciudad que está demandando en estos
espacios y que estos espacios no
necesitamos que sean escenarios grandes
pero que están muy bien no las
producciones tener todos los recursos
escénicos para montar claro que está muy
bien de psoe pero lo cierto es que para
poder hacer teatro solo se necesita a
una persona que camine como dice el peto
y otra que la mire necesitamos
cambiarnos el chip de de que la
producción es algo que necesita nace de
la necesidad perdón que nace en la sede
de del requerimiento del encuentro
y yo creo que voy aquí la hora está en
un momento en que está lista para esos
encuentros estamos en un momento en que
estamos demandando cada vez más están
surgiendo en la ciudad actualmente ya
son 16 las salas alternativas estamos
formando una red de salas alternativas
de wikis donde hay varias
gestores culturales en los que hemos
terminado con convirtiéndonos sin querer
queriendo en gestores culturales
y creo que eso habla muy bien de la
salud de nuestra ciudad a nivel cultural
estamos en un momento de crecimiento es
un momento de unión para apoyarnos
así que los invito a todos a que vayan
conozcan pregunten acerca de su barrio
si hay una sala alternativa si hay un
espacio donde se esté andando y asistan
porque cuando nosotros asistimos
contribuimos a esa a ese crecimiento
contribuimos a que esos encuentros se
generen construimos a encontrarnos como
ciudadanos a dialogar sobre nuestra
producción cultural tenemos acceso a
nuestra
nuestro bagaje a nuestro patrimonio que
tenemos que son nuestros artistas y
nuestra producción cultural entonces mi
invitación es esa realmente al que todos
vengan que todos apoyen que todos
abran su mente y busquen y den
oportunidad y prueben a cosas distintas
porque creo que una de las cosas más
maravillosas que tiene el arte es la
capacidad de sorprendernos y la
capacidad de hacernos de generar
encuentros entre seres humanos entonces
eso solamente es decirles que voy aquí
él está en un buen momento y que para
que siga así depende de todos nosotros
gracias
[Aplausos]